اهلا بكم اعلن الرئيس الروسيه خلال
اجتماعا مع كبار القاده العسكريين انا
روسيا ستحقق كل اهدافها في اوكرانيا رغم
ما وصفه بالاعمال العدائيه من حيث شمال
الاطلسي النيتو وتعهد الرئيس الروسي
بتعزيز قدرات الجيش الروسي العسكري قال
سينما النوويه بشكل دائم ومطرب كما اشاد
بالجنود الرؤوس داعيا قاده العسكريين
الحاضرين الى استخدام
المكتسبه من القتال في سوريا والحمله
العسكريه في اوكرانيا
داخل الروسي تحدث بوتن عن ازمات يعاني
منها المواطن الروسي وضروره العمل على
حلها
سنستمر في تعزيز القدرات القتاليه
والاستعدادات النوويه ما يمثل ضمانا
لسياده روسيا ووحده اراضيها وبشكل عام
الردع النووي والتوازن النووي في العالم
وقد تم تجهيز القوات النوويه بنسبه 91
بالمئه وايضا تم تزويد قواتنا بمنظومه فرط
الصوتيه وايضا تم تزويد القوات للمره
الاولى بمنظومه الصواريخ العابره
[موسيقى]
يتدربون بشكل مناسب والمواطنون يساعدونهم
حيث يقومون بتزويد القوات بالاشياء
والالبسه اضافه الى ذلك يجب ان ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار الانتقادات التي نسمعها المشاكل
موجوده لذلك لا يجب علينا ان نصمت وان
نقوم بحل هذه المشاكل
تنضم الينا من موسكو الينا سبونينا
الباحثه في الشؤون السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
الروسيه ومن كيف ينضم الينا يوفين
ميكتينكو مستشاره وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه اهلا بكما لابدا اولا من موسكو
سيده سبونينا كيف قراتي هذه الملامح
الاوليه لهذه الحمله العسكريه او الخطه
العسكريه الروسيه
مساء الخير لحتى الان تصريحات ااا بوتين
وتصريحات وزير الدفاع روسي لم توضح
ملامح هذه الخطه العسكريه علينا ان نعترف
بهذا الشيء انه لحتى الان توقيت هذا
الهجوم وهمم حتى المرحله كل هذا غير معروف
ولكن السلطات الروسيه اصبحت تلمح اكثر
اكثر انه لابد من التصعيد
وانا من زمان كنت تكلم مع انه لدى روسيا
خطه عسكريه ولكن روسيا غير مستحاجه بتنفيذ
هذه الخطه لانه اي خطا في هذا المجال ممكن
ان يؤدي الى دعايات تاريخيه فعلى روسيا ان
تحضر هذه الخطه بشكل ممتاز لكي تنجح بشكل
كامل ولكنه همم كان قد شرح هذه
الاستراتيجيه همم كل همم الضباط او كبار
القاده العسكريين هل قرات ابرز ملامحها في
هذا اللقاء
وهو شرح هذا الشيء ولكنه بتابعه الحال لم
يدخل في التفاصيل مثلا هو لم يتكلم حول
موضوع من اي جهه سيكون هذا الهجوم من همم
جهه جنوبيه او شرقيه او مثلا من عند حدود
ما بين اوكرانيا وروسيا البيضاء بلا روسيا
انا هذا ما اقصد به انه لا توجد هناك
تفاصيل العسكريه وهي لن تكون لان في غايه
السريه ولكن ملامح كلمه بوتين الاساسيه هي
كتاله انه لابد من الهجوم انه لابد من
السيطره على الاراضي الاكثر في اوكرانيا
ولا بد للاسف من استمرار هذه المواجهه
لفتره اطول من مكان متوقع عليه
واخيرا روسي مستعد ان تتحمل كل هذا وروسيا
مستعده بصمت وحتى عسكريا واقتصاديا روسيا
مستعده لاستمرار هذه المواجهه
كيف قرات مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
كيف قرات هذه الاستراتيجيه عن ماذا تنباع
ابرز الملامح التي من الممكن ان تطبق على
الارض وبالتالي كيف ستتعامل معها اوكرانيا
مساء الخير
شكرا
الحمد لله
الكهرباء موجوده الان
وانترنت موجود بس همم في ساعات يعني طويله
وتطويله عندما ولا كهرباء ولا انترنت
الكبير
[موسيقى]
فسر ما تفسر
ويستخدم الدعايه
الدعايه الشان المستهلك المستهلك الذي
يستمع هي كلمه الذي ينظر على شاشه
التلفزيون
والاخره ولن نحن نعرف جيدا جدا بينا تاثير
تلفزيون في روسيا غير معقول يعني
80% تقريبا من الناس من الروس
ياخذ كل معلومات وكل اخبار مش من الانترنت
بس من التلفزيون طيب
هل هل ما يحدث من مناورات في بلاروسيا
زياره مدريد في فلسطين وايضا الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه التي تحدث عنها بوتن كل ذلك
دعايه قد لا بشيء على الارض
هاي مش دعايه هاي
خطوات يعني بسيطه جدا
زياره الى جاره بالروسيا هاي مش حتى جارهم
هاي جمهوريه من او محافظه
اوكرانيا
كافيه للدفاع عن اوكرانيا اولا طيب
نحن نراقب كله تحركات هناك طيب نحن لا 24
فبراير لما هاجموا قوات روسيه
[موسيقى]
طيب سيده سبونينا ال يعني ضيفي من كيف
يتحدث عن عن انهم مستعدون لاي عمل عسكريا
روسي بالتالي ايضا
بوتن لم يكتفي بذكر ما العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا ولكنه ايضا صوب باتجاه النيتو
وما يقوم به النيتون من اعمال اعدائيه هل
معنى ذلك انه قد تتوسع هذه الحرب وتكون
باستراتيجيه الجديده مختلفه عامه عن السنه
الماضيه او المنصرم
ضيفكم ضيفكم يقول انهم مستعدين للهجوم
ايضا ولكن في نفس الوقت هو يقول انه
كهرباء ما في ماي مافي
والطاقه تتقطع فهذا يعني انه تدمير البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه هي تحضر
بنتائجها يحضر بنتائجها
في روسيا لا توجد مثل هذه المشاكل لا رغم
التشديد العقوبات الغربيه ضدها فهذا يعني
انه اذا كنا نتوقع استمرار هذه المواجهه
فاكرانيا في تقع في موقف اضعف بكثير
بالمقارنه مع روسيا بالنسبه لا كلمه بوتين
اليوم نعم هو لم يدخل في التفاصيل بالنسبه
لملامح الخطه العسكريه القادمه ولكن
اوافق مع طرح من قبل وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيد
وزير الدفاع قد تكلم كثيرا حول مشاريع
تحديث الجيش الروسي بما فيها انشاء فرق
جديده ومن ضمنها فرق خاصه فرق قوات
المظلات وايضا بناء غواصات جديده وسفن
تعمل على محركات نوويه
بتوسيع الحرب لا تذهب الى نزهه وليس فقط
تحديث همم دوري او طبيعي
نعم ما هذا يدل على انه روسيا تحضر نفسها
لشيء جدي وهو اكثر بكثير
بالمقارنه مع المواجهه مع اوكرانيا طبعا
هذا ليس اكيد انه يحدث ولكن احتياط روسيا
تحضر نفس لانه في المواجهه مع اوكرانيا
روسيا اكيد نفهم هذا الشيء انه هي ليست
بحاجه
حديثه وايضا ليست بحاجه للسفن تعمل على
محركات نوويه طيب سيدي افني هل انتم
جاهزون لما همم تريد روسيا اعدادات صواريخ
حديثه خارقه زياده اعداد الجيش الى مليون
ونصف وبالتالي همم حتى الحرب هي معناته
وليس فقط مع اوكرانيا الغربه النيته
امريكا
انا ادعوكم وعدو مشاهدين العربيه ان
يراقبون الخارج خريطه يعني الدول العالم
يعني روسيا كبيره اكبر دوله في العالم
وهي 38 مره افتكر اكبر من اوكرانيا مساحه
اربع مرات اكبر بعد عدد سكان
واكبر
بقدره عسكريه والى اخره
كبير جدا
على على روسيا
اوكرانيا يعني دوله مستقله دوله متواضعه
لدينا اهداف
نحن اسسناها ولكن لا نريد ولا حروب
لن يذهبوا الى نزهه خلال العام القادم
وحتى هذا الشتاء تمام حتى الان يعني كانوا
هجوم روسي
مفاجاه جدا بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
ولكن من البدايه اكيد كان عندهم تقدم الى
اخره ولكن بعدين ما زمن اليوم على فكره
اليوم افتكر هل
301 من بدايه الحرب
وخلال هذه الايام نحن خسرنا بعد من مناطق
بعدين
[موسيقى]
عوده هذه مناطق كيلو اوكرانيا طيب بدايه
الحرب الان روسيا
تحتل
18% من مساحه من اوكرانيا فيما في ذلك
منطقه قرد 18% يعني من منطقه اكثر مساحه
من الامارات المتحده
وضحت الصوره طيب سيد يعني زياره الى
الولايات المتحده هل تعني انه ربما ندخل
بمرحله سلام وليس مرحله حرب
خلال العام القادم
او ضغط من الولايات المتحده اولا تعقيب ان
تعقبا على ما قيل انا اتفق مع ضيفكم
بنقاط معينه ولكن اختلف في بعض النقاط
فاتفق انه هذه كلمه من قبل رئيس بوتين
مواجهه للداخل الروسي صحيح
ولكنها ايضا موجها لدول للغرب
وايضا همم القول انه العمليه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا كانت مفاجاه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
انا اختلف همم في هذا الطرح لانه القياده
الاوكرانيه كانت عارفه هذا الشيء وهمم
وامريكان كانوا عارفاني هذا الشيء
واكثر من ذلك هم لازم ان يفهمه انهم
استفزوا روسيا
واستفزوها عده مرات بشكل مستمر
حتى هذه الخطط بانضمام اوكرانيا الى منظمه
حلف ناته وهي دوله مجاوره لروسيا هذا هو
استفزاز
استفزاز واضح جدا بالنسبه
لابعاد السلام فللاسف للاسف امريكان
يقولون شيء ولكنهم يفعلون شيء اخر فانا لا
اثق بهم اعتقد انه بالعكس تماما سنسمع
التصريحات من قبل انه يدعم لينسكي وسنسمع
ايضا غدا انه امريكا مستمره في امدادات
الاسلحه الثانيه اذا كان هذا الامر هكذا
ويعني لا توجد اي هنيه للسلام لدى امريكا
سيد همم
باختصار لك الحق في الرد على ما تفضل تفضل
به ضيفه
عندما بعد الهجوم يعني ايقاف توسع همم حرف
اطلس
ايقاف توسع خلف اطلس
ولكن ماذا حصل ايه
[موسيقى]
جارنا حصل على
توسيع
الحلف الاطلسي على
1300 كيلو على المال حدود مع روسيا لان
بعد الهجوم
فنلندا والسويد
اتخذوا قرار
بانضمام الى حالتي
فاحتمال سنه الخادمه
سيزداد عدد عدد
للمستقبل مش قريب بس بعيد
اما الان ااه والله لا اعرف مين سوف يقدم
لنا المساعده لان نحن فاهمين روسيا عندها
قدرات هائله دوله كبيره
وهناك يمكن ان نسميها حتى محور الشر
مال روسيا
كوريا
الشماليه ايران وبعد من الدول الاخرى ولكن
اعمارنا ما فيش خيار اخر
الخيار المدافع عن انفسنا ان ندافع عن
بيوتنا وعائلاتنا
لا نريد اراضي الاخرين
شكرا جزيلا
السيد
مستشاره وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني وشكرا
ايضا موصول الى الينا سبونينا الباحث في
الشؤون السياسيه والاستراتيجيه الروسيه
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]